you worked out as a movie theater usher
yeah
uh i got fired for giving away the end
of titanic to a sorority can you imagine
sorority girls couldn't figure out the
world title well they didn't
did that but the thing was they said uh
i go enjoy
they were being [ __ ] to me so i
introduced a movie and i told them the
whole ending to the whole theater
they all died i go the boat sinks leo
dies at the end and they go no he does i
go it's great you think he's sleeping
but he's frozen and they're like why
didn't they all got mad and you got
fired
i got fired i mean they complained to
management that you ruined the end of
time yeah yeah yeah yeah
and weren't you like well wait a second
don't fire me everyone knows what
happened
oh no i started laughing and all the
guys in the box office were laughing and
then when i got fired they all started
laughing even harder
and the other horrible job you have was
driving around uh you worked on the
karate kid movie right no no i worked on
a movie called final payback
with richard grieco and marty cove and
corbin bernsen
and i drove around the evil sensei marty
cove
and you got fired from that too didn't
you yeah because he made me late he
didn't know his lines and he made me dry
and i didn't know l.a
and he was like no take haven hearst you
made me take all these weird lines
and then like i got late and i got fired
it's so great
you